welcome to your mom's house
so it's been a minute and it's
definitely one of the most important
segments we do on the show let's bring
it to you right now with a new
introductory so now here we go
our original demo update music it's
called los temas
do you have a dental one - I have a
couple yeah great
personally I'm really slacking on a
couple things yeah I thought my flossing
is not been as good lately and I really
need to whiten again I have my trays
dude I tell you - what you every time I
see you smile I go look at those yellow
buttery your shit captured I tell you
every fucking time I see you smile
that's the meanest thing somebody could
say to their spouse yeah I'm trying to
help babe you're the worst so look how
white my teeth at I'm gonna I want to
about tonight let's do it tonight
yeah I'll help you we know where your
trays are yeah I got them in the closet
yeah you guys dude seriously it's gonna
burn like hell no really it hurts so bad
remember mmm you look so pretty all
right
hello mommies I am currently sitting in
the parking lot of the dentist's office
after my first visit in over 13 years I
lied to the dentist told him it had been
five years because I could not bring
myself to admit to him shirt in over a
decade you know after my first visit
after my visit you were the first people
I wanted to share this news with much
like my actual mother I'm sure you are
quite disappointed to hear that one of
your own had ignored their oral health
for so long but good news there is
nothing to worry about after 13 years
I am cavity fruit Wow never had one in
my life and didn't require anything
beyond a standard cleaning I'm not sure
if I dodged the bullet and this will put
me back on the right track to proper
dental care or if I just reinforce my
terrible behavior now that I know I can
avoid the dentist for a third of my life
and still be just fine only time will
tell
although my dental care may fall behind
my genes will always stay high and tight
word to your mom Bridget that was just
amazing woman yeah Bridget here's here's
what I'm gonna say you did dodge a
bullet I'm guessing or anything so I
think so but you can't do this stuff
when you're older that's the problem is
when you get in their 30s but yeah but
yeah as you get older it will get more
serious and ya don't
I would consider myself just lucky on
that one you have no cavities you know
if I was her yeah we got another one
let's see hey mommy's I finally went to
the dentist for the first time in ten
years last week guys boy was this
embarrassing after 26 years I still have
a baby tooth the original adult tooth
grew backwards into the palate of my
mouth and was removed the last time I
saw a dentist 10 years ago along with my
five wisdom teeth and it's falling apart
along with that one of my showing teeth
right up front is broken in half
slantways that's what I had and seven
small cavities throughout the rest of my
mouth oh shit right my dentist literally
gave me a D+ grade Oh
so the fillings are covered by insurance
but to get the crowns it's like $900 a
tooth yeah I can have the tube teeth
pulled and get what's called a flipper
tooth yeah just in case you don't know
what that is is basically a retainer
yeah my cousin he's attached to it
that's gonna run me about 450 bucks yeah
yeah yeah I basically want to know
mommies what should I do
what what my mommy's would do sorry I
know Kristina has always said put
yourself in debt for your tea fees we
already we are already paying an $8,000
hospital bill from 10 years ago what do
i do genes machine how expensive is it
to repair a crown I need help
may the toots be strong with you Vanessa
I'll tell you first of all don't avoid
fixing this crowds are expensive here's
what you should do if you can't afford
it if you can't open up a line of credit
ask for care credit I believe it's a
form of dental credit your dentist's
office may have that ya go to a dental
school are you near a major city
I recommend we're near UCLA go to UCLA
and go to a dental student they can do
it for a fraction of the cost and you'll
you know the work will be overlooked
buying whatever dentists and such but
don't go cheap I don't don't get the
flipper I looks like shit my cousin has
a flipper tooth with her retainer yeah I
don't think she has it anymore
oh no I didn't think she I think she got
replaced but it looks like it looks
Pleasant belong there so you know what I
recommend to him if you're paying off
that that you said you don't want to
accrue all kinds of debt one thing and
this doesn't work obviously for
everybody depending on your situation
but a friend of mine did this one time
is that he this was before or like just
sell a kidney right yeah he's a nice old
a child before Obamacare and you know
all those mandatory insurance things but
this happened is that he he laughs the
payment on his insurance on his health
insurance lost it and then was in kind
of a bind obviously for health care and
he went to doctors offices with cash and
said can I get because those doctors
offices and dentists as well are used to
you know maybe funneling some of the
stuff through insurance and they know
they're only getting a percentage of the
amount and all this stuff
so he just went was like if I pay you
cash can I get a discount and they he
got he said yes across the board people
were doing it for a fraction of what
they normally charge because he had cash
money oh and I would say if you have
dental insurance why I think if I've had
it once before and it's kind of a waste
and not only that the dentist that did
take insurance one time I went to and
they took my x-rays and they and the guy
goes oh you have like 12 cavities
remember this and I go that's horseshit
I don't believe you I went to a dentist
didn't tell them I had insurance and
they took the same x-rays and they go
you have no cat than me
no that was me no that was me babe are
you sure yeah on a percent sure are you
sure one no wasn't me - no it did happen
to me and I've told you this story no it
happened to me I had dental insurance
it's just so weird
no I have it happened to me when I
worked it happened to me to them
Glendale its new that it happened to you
so here's what it happened to me okay
this is the first time I'm hearing I've
told you the story multiple times I
worked for the show extreme makeover as
a lawyer god they let us go to the
dentist to get the Zoom Whitening
treatment yeah when I was there they
x-rayed me and the guy goes oh you have
like 17 cavities I was like why don't
and he's like yeah you know we can take
care of them all now I think I'm think
of rain did you have insurance at the
time and that's why he was milking you
for dental insurance yes and so then I
went to another dentist that was covered
under that dental insurance and he was
like no cavities you know zero and I was
blown away by it and then even though
you know that story had happened to you
also can tell you why yeah I had dental
insurance for the first time my life
when I worked at this company yeah and I
swear to god it was in Glendale and the
guy goes oh you got a lot of work to do
we got it I swear I believe me and then
I took it to my Hungarian guy who
doesn't exist anymore you retired by her
that's her fat hair he's gone he's
retired we came to him and he goes
there's no way this guy was totally
scamming you and then I canceled dental
insurance altogether and just paid so I
would get a second opinion is what I'm
trying to say in the cavities on the
cavities and on the extent of the work
that you need it was not a bad idea
actually a lot of times these scumbags
see that you have insurance
I don't know this company bucks and then
they tried to get their money from you
know if it happened to both of us it can
happen if you haven't was it when I was
working in Burbank did we weren't dating
then were we when are you and I were
dating this happened to me this okay
yeah I mean this is a new story but oh
my god
ask Eric Eric if you're listening to
this do you remember when this happens
me because he'll be like I'm everyone
happened to talk don't worry man I
remember oh there's that one of you two
okay can you laugh like an old dad hates
you the most
but anyway why are you have dental
insurance unless it comes with your
company don't pay for that shit there's
no reason you're gonna end up getting
jacked even harder just go to a Russian
dentist I swear to god Russians will do
the work a little bit cheaper too maybe
we don't know where she lives find some
fucking Russians or Eastern blockers
fine foreigner find a foreigner and I
mean that find a foreigner offer them
cash yeah these white dentists that's
the problem is that they do everything
aboveboard you got to go to an immigrant
to do shit the right way yeah go to
Chinatown